dans les aquariums le myriophylle à épi
une plante exotique peut servir de
végétation décorative mais dans nos lacs
et nos rivières où il n'y a pratiquement
pas de limite à son expansion
elle offre un autre genre de décor cette
plante est devenu un envahisseur
redoutable qui cause bien des maux de
tête aux chercheurs et aux arriverai
[Musique]
avec sa longue tige et ses feuilles en
plumes
cette plante aquatique peut sembler
inoffensive
à première vue pourtant depuis plusieurs
années elle envahit nos plans d'eau en
privant de lumière et de nutriments les
plantes indigènes son nom myriophylle à
épi on sait que le mériot fils qui nous
envahit en amérique du nord provient des
comment tout ça s'est propagé d'un
continent à l'autre
bonne question les eaux d'aquarium les
eaux de l'est de navires on ne sera
jamais en définitive mes chaussures
c'est que le mérite il est là et il est
présent maintenant à la grandeur ou
presque du continent nord américain
le biologiste claude lavoie et l'experte
et plantes envahissantes au québec
pour lui rien ne laisse croire que le
myriophylle est une menace pour la santé
humaine
c'est d'abord et avant tout une duse en
salle usage des lieux nuance pour la
navigation pour la baignade pour la
pêche sportive depuis 2007 claude lavoie
observe et analyse le myriophylle pour
mieux le combattre la présence de cette
plante exotique dans les plans d'eau de
vie est un véritable cauchemar pour les
riverains le meilleur fils c'est pas
juste un problème biologique savoir un
bain est plus complexe à c'est un
problème de dimension à la fois
sociologique économique politique et on
peut comprendre qu'une personne qui a
beaucoup investi de sa propriété
riveraine soit vraiment tenté de s'en
débarrasser dans les meilleurs
les parce que il ya un effet émotif
associé à sa première chose à savoir on
les radicaux jamais donc on est pris
avec cette espèce loeb pour plusieurs
décennies pour ne pas dire plusieurs
siècles la particularité de cette plante
exotique c'est qu'elle se reproduit très
facilement à vitesse grand v
à la mi-juillet des racines se forme sur
ces tiges les branches et les feuilles
s'en détache en se fragmentant la
plupart de ces fragments vont mourir sur
les rives mais un faible pourcentage
d'entre eux va s'enraciner en 3 et 4
mètres de profondeur ces nouveaux
herbiers vont alors envahir le fonds du
plan d'eau au québec près de 200 lacs
sont envahis par le myriophylle à épi
est sous l'eau une lutte sans merci
s'est engagé ici au lac des abénakis le
moyen utilisé pour mater l'envahisseur
c'est le bâchage synthétique qu'on
appelle aussi à quoi screen
je trouve personnellement que son poil
qui se manipule bien particulièrement
petit donc un plongeur seul peut la
transporter dans l'eau
vincent gagné l étudiant d'autres lots
de la voix comme jeunes chercheurs c'est
dans ce vaste laboratoire naturel qu'il
a fait ces stages en environnement en
il est embauché pour coordonner les
travaux de lutte ou myriophylle vous
voulez plongeant retrouver les bénévoles
cibler les endroits où est ce qu'on va
poser des toiles cibler les endroits où
est ce qu'on va faire de l'arrachage
pour l'installation des toiles on est on
est deux plongées dans l'eau avec une
personne bénévole en surface
les plongeurs vont descendre sous l'eau
avec la toile ils vont aller là déroulé
puis ensuite de saint lô plongeant va
l'installer les tests sont des bords de
la membrane synthétique agit alors comme
une barrière physique qui étouffe le
myriophylle aeby l'objectif réduire de
85% les zones infestées de la nouvelle
expertise que je deviens pas réglé ça
c'est pas savoir si les toiles de fibre
de verre fonctionneront aussi qu'elle
fonctionne c'est plutôt de regarder la
lutte sur plusieurs années la planifier
de manière stratégique sur l'ensemble
d'un lac
ailleurs au québec
une autre stratégie est utilisé pour
s'attaquer aux myriophylle le bâchage
avec des toiles de jute ou à partir de
bateaux ancrés des plongeurs vont fixer
les toiles sur les herbiers ce qui les
prive de lumière quand on a des plans
d'eau qui sont largement affectés qu'on
a des airs bis qui on est très grande
superficie avec des dossiers qui sont
très très fortes
donc on va avoir un meilleur coût
bénéfice d'y aller avec le jeu les
associations de riverains du lac
brompton ont mandaté jean françois
martel et son équipe de plongeurs pour
combattre l'indésirable ici dans le cas
spécifique du lac brompton
c'est que on a un envahissement qui est
là depuis quand même plusieurs années on
a des superficies verbier le qui peuvent
dépasser les 10 mille mètres carrés
l'estrie est l'une des régions québec
les plus contaminés par le myriophylle
avec les projets qu'on a mises en place
comme l'utilisation du jeu par exemple à
la charge avec des toiles de jute
on est capable d'avoir des très très bon
résultat pour optimiser ses
interventions jean françois martel
utilise en plus des toiles de jute
une autre technique pour le moins
étonnante
l'arrachage manuel avec un aspirateur
aquatique
les plongeurs vont arracher les plants
de façon manuelle et vont utiliser
l'aspect rios fil pour remonter les
fragments donc on est capable d'être
beaucoup plus efficace de faire beaucoup
plus de travail en fait dans nos heures
de plongée dans une journée tous les
fragments qui sont retirés du plan d'eau
c'est considérer un peu comme dans
matières contaminées si on veut oui ce
serait compostables mais dans le fond
pour réduire les risques de
contamination dans un autre plan d'eau
le ministère de l'environnement vont
nous demander de les envoyer à
l'enfouissement
depuis trois ans les riverains du lac
brompton et les trois municipalités
concernées ont déboursé plus de 320
milles dollars pour les opérations de le
taux myriophylle un investissement qui a
rapporté le bâchage avec des toiles de
jute combiné à l'arrachage manuel ont
permis de réduire de 75% les zones
infestées
à granby on a opté pour cette faucheuse
aquatique
la ville souhaite limiter temporairement
les nombreuses inconvénients dus à la
présence du myriophylle eyed peas dans
le lac boivin les techniques de fauche
sont testés depuis plusieurs décennies
aux états unis elles ont toujours été un
échec
la raison est simple c'est qu'on coupe
la plante mais on va pas affecter le
système racinaire
donc c'est un peu comme quand on tond la
pelouse après avoir tendu la pelouse ça
repousse et c'est exactement ce que ça
fait chaque année le faux quart d'heure
est en opération de juillet à octobre
ils quadrillent uniquement 20 % de la
superficie du lac au mois de juillet ou
aux focales seulement qu'à 50
centimètres de la surface et au mois de
septembre et octobre l'on descend à un
pied du fond donc une très grande
quantité de plantes aquatiques qui sont
récupérés
ça peut être utile pour dégager des
couloirs de navigation pendant la
période x pour lequel on ne peut pas
avoir deux mairies offices mais on n'a
jamais venu à bout d'une invasion de
mérilheu fil avec des techniques de
faucardage ou toute autre technique
faisant appel à de la mécanique
ici ou là boivin l'enjeu principal de la
ville c'est de conserver les activités
aquatiques pour y arriver
la ville a déboursé près de 200 mille
dollars pour acquérir ce faux quart
d'heure pour granby c'était la meilleure
solution disponible
l'étoile synthétique et de jute n'était
pas d option abordable
on évalue à superficie puis avec les 385
milles mètres carrés sur mais delajoux
c'est pratiquement trois quarts de
million
et si on met de côté la toile
synthétique c'est environ 45 millions le
lac boivin est l'endroit idéal pour la
propagation du myriophylle à épi il est
peu profond ce qui donne plus de lumière
à la plante et stimule sa croissance
puis son principal affluent de la
rivière yamaska nord est bordée de
terres agricoles
d'où proviennent les engrais à l'origine
de la prolifération du myriophylle le
ministère de l'environnement a autorisé
ce faucardage à la condition que la
ville interviennent en amont auprès des
agriculteurs à court terme
on se regarde mais un moyen et à long
terme on veut vraiment que les pratiques
soient changés afin de diminuer l'apport
des pesticides et la porte du phosphore
qui est vraiment la problématique c'est
la griffe phosphore qui créent des
baumes de plantes aquatiques 6 mai il y
à d'autres phénomènes qui contribue à
l'intrusion du myriophylle à épi dans
les cours d'eau
et puis normalement d'études sur la
propagation du myriophylle d'un lac à
l'autre et la plupart pointent vers les
embarcations comme principal vecteur de
fragments d'un lock-out l'interception
des embarcations en particulier qui sont
potentiellement porteuses de myriophylle
est le facteur clé pour éventuellement
se prémunir contre l'invasion de ce
spécia au coeur du mont saint-hilaire
voici le lac
airtel un véritable havre de paix depuis
plus de 50 ans le lac fait partie de la
réserve naturelle gold de l'université
mcgill un sanctuaire reconnu par
l'unesco
ici aucun plaisanciers ne peut pratiquer
d'activités aquatiques
malgré tout cela commence à être en
veille par le myriophylle à épi en
marchant sur la rive on voit que
beaucoup de fragments de myriophylle de
chou et donc ça laisse penser que
l'infestation est quand même importante
pour veiller à la conservation du lac
airtel la biologiste et wengen mère
travaille depuis plusieurs années avec
l'université mcgill
[Musique]
un temps donné qu'on est dans un milieu
protégé qui pratiquement pas utilisé
sauce par les chercheurs de l'université
les étudiants de l'université mcgill
c'est un milieu intéressant à observer
et on peut se poser la question comment
elle est arrivée ici comme ici le lac
airtel on est quand même assez près de
la rivière richelieu
on soupçonne les oiseaux migrateurs qui
pourrait faire des courtes distances qui
pourrait déposer des fragments ça peut
être une patate mais pour plusieurs
chercheurs la dissémination du
myriophylle par les oiseaux serait
marginale par rapport à celles
provoquées par les humains une
recommandation serait d'intervenir tôt
dans la gestation pour être en contrôle
la biologiste devra proposer un mode
d'intervention pour combattre cette
invasion et ce sera le bâchage avec des
toiles synthétique à sainte-aurélie en
beauce
l'heure est au bilan vincent gagner son
équipe retire les toiles synthétique
installée depuis le début de l'été on
est optimiste je pense que la situation
avec les abénakis est pas inquiétant ce
qu'on a fait ça porte fruit de ce qu'il
faut c'est continuer pc ça se fait sur
le long terme après quatre ans
d'intervention les résultats sont
encourageants en 2016 le milieu fils
couvrait trente six mille mètres carrés
au lac des abénakis aujourd'hui les
zones infestées ont été réduits et à
9000 m² le quart de ce qu'elles étaient
il ya quatre ans
mais le travail est loin d'être terminé
j'estime que dans les prochaine ou
l'année d'après l'ong ont un seuil qui
va être acceptable mais ça sera pas
terminée parce qu'il va falloir
continuer à surveiller l'apparition de
nouveaux plans l'apparition de nouveaux
servier au garde des sceaux sur le
combat contre l'invasion du myriophylle
aeby dans nos cours d'eau sera long et
coûteux pour les biologistes c'est le
prix à payer pour protéger de manière
efficace tous nos écosystèmes
quand on comprend les écosystèmes et
qu'on regarde dans certains milieux
l'impact des espèces exotiques
envahissantes c'est très rapide et très
grasse et on a un grand intérêt à
conserver nos écosystèmes à conserver la
biodiversité parce que quand on a un
équilibre une bonne biodiversité aux
écosystèmes sont plus résilient
changements climatiques tempêtes de
verglas et cetera
mais si les gens réalisent à quel point
les lacs ce sont des écosystèmes
fragiles et que le meilleur film n'est
qu'un problème permis d'autres ça je
pense qu'on aura fait un vrai progrès au
niveau de la science de l'environnement
des lacs et il en cent de la population
seront mieux à même de profiter de ces
écosystèmes